what's goody hot breath verse we are
back with our weekly hot breath live
this is a very special edition you know
our mission here is to help cultivate
the next generation of self-made comics
and our guest today we're going to start
bringing on guests here okay we're going
to start getting out into the hot breath
of verse getting out there learning from
the comics that are out there on that
selfmade hustle firsthand and our guest
today he was on I look back a little
over a year ago to promote his first
ever comedy special he self-produced so
you guys can check that out and now he's
back filming another special and he's
here to tell the tale of the things he's
learned the hard way so you don't have
to and Yoshi is about to film a special
as well so maybe there's some good
learnings that Yoshi can um get before
diving in and making all the mistakes in
the from the first one that we all do
when we produce a special but who we're
talking about is New York City's finest
Adam Mueller everyone please welcome
him to the
show let's
for Adam Mueller welcome back buddy
congratulations on filming a second
special I have you been doing comedy
seven years yeah yeah that's you almost
you nailed it almost because I remember
before the last special it was almost
six years
okay because I was gonna say that's
almost creepy how you knew that I'm a
fan Adam I'm a fan oh I appreciate that
I appreciate it did you start on
February 3rd
yeah at a Open Mic at 5:00
p.m you went third and you did that
weird joke about the
closet yeah it was me so people are
going to listen to this not only because
they love hot breath but because they
want to learn how to produce their own
special and you doing it twice now I
think there's a lot that we can all
learn from this so I mean the one thing
that's top of mind to me is you're
you're doing two specials within seven
years of your comedy career what are you
thinking yeah what's the what's going
through your mind it's a great question
right because yeah what's the strategy
behind that thought there
Adam because and I you know because if
like if I'd never done the first one
right then the second one would have
could have in Theory been that much
better I suppose
um if you take two hours of material and
you cut it down to the best hour it's
going to be better um but look I think I
got so much out of the first one um it I
got we talked about it a year ago I got
very lucky that it came out as well as
it did from a production standpoint you
know the the jokes I I was
um uh proud enough of to make public in
that
way and initially when I when I
committed to the first one I was like
the worst case is I just get a bunch of
you know Instagram
Clips um and then it turned into
something um much more
significant and um and also started you
know and something that actually you
know it's it's fun when you sort of
pivot in comedy and you start getting
paid for some of this hard work so being
yeah say that one more time say say that
part um because the uh I mean the audio
version of that first special is now on
Sirus so you know that's you start to
get there starts to be multiple Avenues
to kind of recoup some of this um effort
you've put in for sure and I had so I'd
cut so much out of the first
one um that you know a year later I was
like oh there's enough you know you keep
writing every day you have the stuff you
cut out of the first one or that didn't
quite get over the Finish Line in time
you're like there's enough for a second
one um and I I work I'm very productive
when I put a flag in the ground and say
if I'm not ready by this date I will
embarrass myself it really helps me get
stuff done yeah but the idea of like
doing a second one instead of holding
off was I felt like I had the material I
felt like it would
be 50% better than the first one which
was kind of an important sort of
theoretical concept to me because
there's no point in doing one that's
exactly you know you got if you're not
improving something's gone wrong
especially in like the actual product
that you put out for everyone to
see and um
and I and I wanted to just have more out
there more way more um more things for
people to watch more Clips more tracks
on SiriusXM more YouTube views
Etc yeah and I also don't I think it's
become very very hard to burn material
as well so it's not I'm not worried
about it being out there if that makes
sense that wasn't a
concern
gotcha yeah so you're you're you're on a
Content Quest that's yeah so that's
that's what I was going to say is it's
so it's interesting it used to and this
is and I'm asking you this because
literally this past weekend I worked
with a comedian San Francisco named
Helen Chu who's hilarious been doing it
si like six years and she was talking
about about the film a special so we
were talking about the timeline of like
how the old school mentality of filming
a special to now it's like it's like
just getting something out there to
promote yourself as a just that I do
comedy and I get content from it it's
not necessarily doing the hour it's more
of all the content you'll get from just
having this high quality production of
your
comedy yeah and it's sort of like a
proof of concept of yourself as a
comedian because you know look it's
really it's become increasingly
difficult well we we could argue this we
could debate this it's become
increasingly difficult to get say like a
late night set there's less late night
shows I feels like they don't like
several of them don't really put comics
on that often um yeah and so and so that
as that as sort of
a uh as a sort of proof of concept that
you're funny enough to get you know
booked by people it's it's trickier to
get that but what we've evolved into is
this DIY world so if if the if you think
you're good enough um for that kind
of recognition and and you're not but
but it's hard to get you know figure out
a way to G get it for yourself and it's
not quite the same of course but I was
sick of being brought to stage with no
real credit other than whatever the last
Festival I went to so I was like well
what if why can't my credit be YouTube
special I'll have to do is make one yeah
um and and and then it goes in the email
to when I'm when we're reaching out to
Bookers to say here here's an hour watch
any part of it like I can you
know yeah and and I think I think that
has helped get my you know because part
of it is just getting the emails read
right
like because if you're a Booker you're
getting inundated with these emails you
can't read them all um so having sort of
a special out there I think helps with
that and I don't know why having a
second one wouldn't help more especially
if it's
better yeah and I can't imagine a Booker
thinking oh this person's done two
specials they're doing too many specials
I think the opposite would be oh this
comedian
is grinding like this comedian is
writing and performing a lot developing
material a lot like they are taking the
career seriously as opposed to oh maybe
they did one too early and the material
wasn't quite ready I think people would
see it as this comic is putting in the
work and willing to put themselves out
there yeah look I think it's you know
I've sort of had this theory of the goal
each year is to get rejected as many
times as
possible because I don't want to I don't
want to I don't want to have a goal
where I have to get something because
that's out of my control but I can
control sub how many things I submit to
I could control the work and effort I
put in and if they don't if if the end
of that they don't want it or they don't
want me or whatever it is that's okay um
but if I get if you get if you get
rejected 100 times that 101st thing
might actually work you know um so so
there's part of that and you know I also
um over the last like since the first
one came out I I I'm not afraid to I
have no I have a pretty thick skin I'm
not afraid to submit to anything so I
cold emailed a few like late night uh
Bookers and with with the set said hey
this set I think this set is good enough
for your your show here it is and um it
was written a little more professionally
than what I just said uh but in one case
that you know you you send a unique
YouTube link to the set right and it got
it got viewed six times and then I got
an email back and was the first time
that had happened which said thanks for
submitting we're going to pass but
please resubmit but you know at the end
of the year so of course you do and then
that one got passed on and never got
watched and that's just that's just part
of the game um but I think there's
something about submitting again to
promote a special that's coming out that
maybe gives it a better chance of
getting looked at so it's just it's it's
just doing all those little things like
and I will I'll send another five minute
set like when I know you know when the
special's coming out and say I'd love to
do this set on your show and promote my
special and maybe they'll watch it maybe
they won't but I think it's got a better
chance than just another kind of random
email yeah you're just putting up shots
yeah you're putting up shots and that's
that's awesome and I think to your point
where in this day and age where shots is
really where like the magic happens you
just got to put up a lot of shots in a
lot of places that's a very unique way
when you mentioned the rejection letters
I never thought about it that way yeah
but it's like all right how many
rejection letters can I get actually
makes you more excited when you actually
get a rejection letter so when a when
something does pop off you're like I
didn't even see this coming that's great
when you it's so much easier just to
send some emails and then forget you
sent them and then every once in a while
if a reply pops up it's like holy holy
crap they read it that works that works
wa
what and Al look I also think um I also
think the first special was instrument
in um getting me a dry bar which I'm
taping in a few weeks now you are yeah
that's right yeah congratulations my
submission from a from the dry bar was
just a chunk of the first
special yeah awesome dude that helped so
you you know it's you don't always get
what you like what you're trying to get
you might you get but you might you'll
get something and then you just keep you
keep building and you you know have
gratitude for what you do get Focus you
can control gratitude Adam's preaching
here
Yoshi he's just he's just I mean like I
mean we might well if you if you work
hard and create stuff you're proud of
it'll work out right yeah Minister M
preaching to the choir I see you
Minister M uh so the first one to the
second one what do what did you do
differently uh and what did you learn
about doing the second one yeah let's
get into the let get into the special
now Yoshi's about to film one everyone
listening has filmed one or is like
aspired to someday or just want to learn
the process yeah let's get into the
weeds here all right so just if we
quickly recap of the first one just to
set the stage yes you know I I um I
filmed it at a club that had a a very
good house camera that I could crank up
to you know 4K Etc I had a comic that
had his own version of the exact of that
camera as well so now I had two great
cameras and then instead of uh hiring a
film crew I bought myself a nice camera
for the third main camera and then found
some cheap cameras lying around found
some Zoom recorders put them all over
the room and hoped for the best and you
know 10 minutes before I was on stage I
was still fiddling with equipment right
um that's not how to do
it
that's I mean that's not how to do it
but it got you a dve
yeah no if if that's look if you're on a
shoestring budget you can film something
in the worst case is you don't end up
putting it out that's the worst case so
if you haven't spent much money then who
cares you know yeah um yeah and and I
got very lucky too that after the fact
someone uh a guy named Jason Katz who's
now filmed and directed a ton of these
specials um reached out to me and and he
didn't realize I'd already sort of
filmed and said I'd love to direct your
special I saw you doing something and I
I had said to him oh wow and he sent me
his resume and stuff and it's so
impressive um I said I would have
reached out to you but like I didn't
think you'd want to do mine in a million
years given names on the list um yeah I
mean he he did all three of Joe lists I
think he did one of Sam Mill's he's
worked on Mark Norman's he's he's
directing Rachel Feinstein's for Netflix
right now um ni so he's so he's busy and
very very good so but he was gracious
enough where I said why don't I give you
all the footage and the audio stuff and
you do it from you take it from here and
I think that's one of the reasons it
turned out so well because he knew what
he was doing um in the post- production
so I got very lucky there and then this
time around I was like hey can you just
do the whole thing this
time and um so it was helpful one that
he he already knew me and my comedy and
kind of the vibe I give off and he'
edited and directed the first one
um he just hadn't filmed it so that
helped and we filmed it at the exact
same Club but the idea was we want to
make it look and feel very
different so that's why you see like
there's the light like we brought in he
brought in his own lights this time he
um we created a little like Haze in the
room which looks very very cool with the
lights we covered up the back wall with
a
curtain um the angles are slightly
different and you know of course the
quality of equipment was just next level
versus what we'd had the first time
nice so and I didn't and I didn't you
know I got to the club the the first
show was I think s either 7 or 7:30 I
got to the club at 5 and like
everything's set up so you recorded two
shows we did two shows two show yeah
that's an important
distinction um although
uh it's interesting doing the second
show
um I didn't I as it turned out I didn't
need it and I think it's I suspect it
happens a lot where you get it on the
first
show because it's like especially you
know the first show is like 7 or 7:30
the second Show's 9:30 it's later you
know this the first show was pretty much
sold out the second show wasn't quite as
full yeah um it was a Thursday night so
people still have to work the next day
they're a little tired at the Late Show
and I was tired because I'd just done it
and what we did is like um and I ran the
set and then stayed up there and we did
some pickups repeated some jokes we did
some other stuff and when I got I was on
stage probably like 90 minutes on that
first show and when I got off I was like
hey I think we got it should we just
cancel the Late
Show
um of course we didn't and The Late Show
was still fun but you I could tell
within five minutes of starting that
show that like
oh I'm not you know it's going to be
hard to get something on this show
that's any better than what we've got
for sure and I think we've got we're
using a couple lines maybe and maybe one
joke from the second show got it so it's
99% the first the first show and the
pickups at the end which are really
helpful what is the pickup yeah what do
you mean what' you do so what so what I
mean is um so I did the set right as
planned and it was about 70 minutes
which was deliberate because I wanted to
be able to cut a bunch of stuff out I I
don't want to do a 70-minute special but
I want to have the flexibility to decide
what to keep um and then you know it was
it ends everyone applauds everyone
because it's got that great sort of uh
special event energy right because
there's people there to see you but even
people that didn't know me um that
bought a ticket like it's advertisers
this is a special recording event they
come in they see these five massive
cameras a smoke machine cool lights
they're like oh this is a cool thing so
there's that energy Vibe and then um but
I don't walk I don't leave the stage I
stand there and then um and the host at
the beginning has already said when the
show ends stay in your seats this is a
recording so we might want to pick a few
things up and then the the Jason the
director had had um identified a few
jokes he wanted me to
redo so I had to get back in the kind of
moment of those jokes and do them
again which was weird it there there's
some funny footage of me trying to start
jokes at that point oh that sounds
hilarious and but but the crowd gets
super hyped because now they're they're
seeing the sausage get made and they're
super excited and the laughs like the
noise on the pickups was probably the
loudest part of the
show um and it's things you don't think
of like I think there's one joke you
know he doesn't he's not going to tell
me I just need this one line he's just
because it's in the moment he's gonna
said just do that joke again and then
when I looked at the footage after the
problem was i' I'd taken a on one of
them right I'd taken a sip of water and
I'd started the first line of the joke
before I put the water back on the stool
right so he just needed me to like I did
the whole joke again but what he really
just needed was the very beginning and
then you can cut back to the first one
once the water's been put back yeah
stuff like that you just don't really
think about it there was one where I
flubbed I flubbed a
line um and after he and I did the so he
just shouted from the back of the room
like you know do the animal doctor joke
again do that joke again do that joke
again and he had three and then he's
like do you have any and I had a
couple that I just kind of mentally
noted on the way through which was sort
of weird to try to remember and then I
did those um yeah and that was like
another you know 15
minutes nice and then uh and then you're
like oh we got like we got great
versions of everything
now
that's sweet but it's
exhausting I could imagine doing that
for 90 minutes and then yeah having to
do it again for another in essence
another 90 minutes did you do pickups at
the second show too second show he did
not have any pickups but that's also
because he knew what he'd gotten on the
first show because there was plenty of
mistakes on the second show and uh there
was one thing at the end I realized that
I on the first show I'd forgotten a
tag and um and on the second show I'd
done the same joke again and I'd also
forgotten the tag so I just readed the
joke just to get the
tag yeah um so that we could kind of
give us the chance to put that in
because it was I didn't that's one of
those tags where I didn't want to leave
out yeah for sure yeah I'm not
earthquake I'm not good enough to leave
out a good tag well one take Quake is
what Earth take qu well that's what he
said on the podcast you know one we got
in and out yeah yeah I forgot the John
Wick tag that's funny even even someone
his take Adam I think would be my
nickname yeah that's really cool I knew
I've like I've heard of pickups in like
you know TV shows and acting and things
like that but on it was interesting to
hear that on a comedy special so I was
curious to hear what yeah what you were
actually trying to re-shoot there so
yeah that's cool yeah then they filmed
me a few times like walking onto St like
we did a few like fake walk ups and
leaving the stage and stuff just to get
as much footage as they could because
you know the more you get the more you
can the more flexibility you have just
in case you need it um you learn that
from the first one too yeah absolutely
because the last thing you want to do is
have to cut something just because you
didn't quite get the right stuff on tape
when you know it's a good joke and you
know it fits in that sort of set of
material that you know because you don't
necessarily want to save it for the next
one kind of thing for sure and on the
second show I was pretty loose so I
threw in some stuff I hadn't done on the
first show I was just like oh let's go
for it I'll do this other chunk because
who knows yeah and um and we're not
going to end up you know we we we'll
we'll bump that to the eighth special at
this point but uh he's gonna film
another one in six months everyone don't
worry another one he's like the DJ khed
of Comedy another
one you must be just ch like writing all
the time performing all the time like to
even to just develop an hour of talking
on stage in a year is you know that
that's no easy feat at any level of this
game so like going from the first to the
second how were you able to develop this
so quickly you know besides your
experience so much in the Hot Breath
Right 10 club and being a winner of our
right 10 contest we would do in the
pandemic so you know besides all that
how are you able to develop stuff so
fast and feel confident enough besides
knowing us as your comedy Brethren well
the new hour was just 10 right 10
contest sets back to back to back and
um so that's pretty legit actually
that's not a terrible be a fun to put
together a special every joke
is oh traffic I got a new one
guys there were a couple kind of like
core jokes that I missed on the first
one and um not deliberately like I just
ran out of time and forgot and I only
had the one show and there were no real
there was no one there was no one kind
of directing that could be like hey you
forgot to do that joke you know um I
mean I did I actually did do a few
pickups the first time on the the first
special there was actually someone in
the audience a comic who good friend of
mine who shouted out at the end of the
show you forgot the skydiving
joke do the sky and then I did it and
it's in there and I and if you see me do
the joke I kind of point at him when I
start it like thanks for reminding me um
that's funny so there was a little bit
of that on the first one but there
wasn't like a director who's like here
the things you need to redo or here's
what you missed um so there was a couple
like jokes like some of my two of my
favorite jokes that I just missed and a
so I already had that for the second one
and then there was a bunch of stuff I'd
probably I'm gonna guess like 20 to 30%
of the L special uh the second special
was written um at least in it's like
you know 80 90% of the way there before
I filmed the first one so it's not like
it was all new material that was
generated post filming of the first
special got um and like you know in
theory the third one has started the
same way there's still a bunch of stuff
that didn't make the second one and you
start with that and you kind of keep
going and so it's not it's not all
unique material that was written in a
year it was stuff that's um it was also
like extensions of certain themes from
the first
one yeah
so are you PL already planning on a
third like I've got right now I've got
three different
um ideas about a third one if that makes
sense and I kind of as a way of just
keeping the writing fresh I kind of work
on them all simultaneously and we'll see
which kind of gets there
first
nice but
yeah Yoshi you're about to film a
special uh you Adam's right here he just
walked through the fire oh yeah I can
give you some other things that I that I
like I made a little list of things
after this most recent one for the next
one yo send that list over yeah but it's
things like um like before the show
before the show do not be shy about
saying everyone get the F out of the
Green Room I need my own
space like if there's could be sound
people camera people the manager of the
club whoever friends other Comics like
you know you want some space to yourself
just to collect your thoughts like just
don't be you know don't be shy tell
everyone to get the heck out of there um
that's one thing um on a technical side
anything anything that if you're talking
to the sound engineer or the
videographers or whatever and you ask
for something right weeks in advance
months in advance and they say oh yeah
yeah we'll bring in that six
camera immediately email them after the
conversation and say just to like
memorialize our conversation you
committed to bringing a six camera so
it's like in writing and you've sent it
and remind them a week before if it's
anything that's different from like kind
of their
usual thing just because you know people
forget and they get on autopilot and
they just do what they usually do um and
if you wanted anything special you got
to make sure to remind people um that's
a big one
and um I don't want it to sound like I
did but don't phone in the late show or
the second show Even if you got it on
the first first one like I do wish
there's a part of me that wishes I just
stuck a little more to the script for
the second one and treated it like
approached it as if I didn't think I had
it yet I wish I you know if that makes
sense I think I was a little too too
loose and casual and too much like I got
it so this is cool like I should have
pretended like I don't have it
pressure's on you know um yeah it's
another another thing that I think is
helpful
um what was your rehearsal process from
the first to the second and did you
change it up oh the well the second one
I benefited a lot because I actually had
some headliner sets gotcha you know the
the first one was an hour cobbled
together at five minute open mics right
largely and yep and then you know some
10 minute and 15 minute sets and I was
featuring a little bit so I got to do a
few but I never did it all at once in
front of a crowd before the taping which
is yeah that was your first time doing
an hour was your comedy special tape
correct yeah yeah first time I'd ever
done an hour um was the taping mhm which
is you know an interesting approach and
not anything I would recommend but it
was you know it was that's the that's
the situation I was in so um this time I
had you know what four or five headliner
sets in the few months leading up to it
where I you know did most of
it um or versions of it that I would
then of course adjust and edit so that's
that's helpful and I but I still did the
same thing I did the first time which is
for a few months almost every day um at
least five times a week I just turned on
a stopwatch grabbed the mic off the mic
stand in my apartment and did it to the
wall and that I found that really helped
just get it in my head and I also like
would Riff to myself and I came up with
tags I wrote a couple there's a couple
jokes in there that were written in the
weeks leading up to the taping that were
just me riffing in my living room
as I did it and was like oh that's
that's funny and that's a fun way to get
from you know that point this point to
that point I'll put that in um yeah yeah
yeah and and I found that incredibly
helpful and I you know also and I still
do that now as just a way of writing as
well just I got like a half finish joke
just grab the mic and pretend I'm doing
it and see what comes
out there's something about actually
speaking out loud that's so different
than thinking in your head for sure of
course talking is writing as well like
just trying to talk out a joke I mean
that's Mark Norman that's what he said
on the podcast is how he writes he just
walks around a hotel room like a crazy
man just yeah saying his jokes out loud
and I've I've heard several Comics say
that's how they write and it feels weird
at first but then it works as well I did
one other thing different this time and
and I guess I would recommend recomend
it if you have the
time um but what I did was like two or
three months
before I started going through videos
and every joke that's in the special
like I kind of had the set the current
set list and I would clip I'd clip up
every set into individual jokes and then
I would take the best truest version of
each
joke right and I created like a
Frankenstein video of the whole
hour but with the best version of each
joke and then I could just and I could
pull I could either watch that video or
I could pull the audio off and just go
for a walk and just listen to each joke
murdering because it's the you know and
so I kind of I called it the
Frankenstein set because it's like 10
different clubs you know it's and every
time I do a set then after I had it if I
got a better version of a particular
joke or if I changed the wording and I
got a nice clean version of it I would
swap it out
and I just kept listening to that as
well that takes a little time but it's
interesting and then you it helps you
with the timing
too that's cool to hear yeah you're
you're woring about the production side
of things and all that but you're also
living in the set almost you're
listening to it you're rehearsing it
you're saying it out loud you're not
just saying oh well I have the jokes let
me just figure out how to film it but
you're actively just burning this into
your brain every
day yeah you know and creating the
connections between the different like
blocks of material so that it seems like
so that it
makes so that like so that it makes
sense to me like why would I talk about
going to New Orleans after I talked
about living in New York kind of thing
like and it's it's also just a way for
me to remember the order I want it to be
in because because it you end up doing
that and you end up the biggest impact
of that is probably one tags you think
of a lot of tags I mean most of them
don't work but if you get a couple that
end up working you know as you're as
you're not on the night of but as you're
preparing then great um but also like
you you you rethink the order because
you're going through it so much you're
like I actually think this junk makes
way more sense up here kind of
thing there's a good question from the
live chat here from Tim ketchersid
which is one of the perks of joining our
weekly live streams every Tuesday at 5:
pm on our YouTube channel you can ask
questions directly and Tim asked Adam
are you comfortable talking about budget
for the first special and how it
compares to the second
special yeah absolutely um the way
that's worded I can answer that
um the second the second one probably
cost me actually put it put it in tater
tots how many tater tots
well how much is a tater top the second
one is probably two and a half to three
times more expensive than the first one
um and and that's and there's maybe like
and now there's some let's say optional
costs to come because partly um you know
you I wanted to wait until I'd seen a
couple a couple of the edits before I
really sort of knew oh this is pretty
good um and now that I'm on the maybe
the third edit is probably coming to me
in the next couple days um so now I'm
I'm trying to decide like maybe I should
hire a PR firm for when this comes out
maybe I should there's some other you
know now I start formulating like the
marketing plan to actually release the
thing because I really kind of I know
what I have
now um and that's an additional cost
that I don't I actually don't know what
that would be but that's something I'll
be looking
into so what was the the two and a half
to three times what what were those
additional costs
oh um all right so I had a you know I
had there was a hair and makeup person
this time oh yeah it doesn't you know so
if you if you look at it you're like it
didn't help oh trust me how much worse
it would have been uh without them but
uh which by the way is also important
for the multiple shows because you want
to try to look exactly the same on the
second show and you're you've just
exerted a lot of effort so um I didn't
have too much makeup but like the powder
that makes you not shiny
um is is helpful and then there was a
photographer so there's like you're
running around with lots of still
pictures which will be helpful for
promotion and stuff and are just kind of
fun to have those aren't huge costs but
then really just like the a proper you
know videographer crew because every
camera was manned they weren't just on
tripods filming right there was one
there was a roving guy that had the
thing strapped to him on a gimbal that
could walk around the room and get some
interesting shots um so I think there
was the crew of
uh four or five so paying you know the
for the I guess the rental of the
equipment and their
time that adds that's really the bulk of
the additional cost sure the first one
we had one camera was manned by a comic
whose camera it was who volunteered to
do it so it was you know as a favor
which is a very different um which is
also something by the way I wouldn't
recommend doing make sure you not he did
a great job fantastic job but when when
someone's doing you a favor and it's
essentially free it's harder to boss
them around and tell them how you want
them to do it if you pay someone
something you're like here I want you to
do this and it's it's much easier to do
that although I didn't boss anyone
around the second time either because
that was you know I trusted the director
to have everything figured out and and
he and he did because he's he's very
good at
these how did how did did you decide
even in the filming how did you decide
where to put the cameras and how many
you wanted to have so even if you could
break down yeah the the production of
what the setup was yeah so there were I
think there were five cameras so there
was there was kind of a classic head-on
view um then there was a head-on view
that was on a like a track so it just
moves back and forth which is kind of a
cool you know image and then there was
there were two like diagonal
views and then there was the guy with
the camera attached to him um I think
that's five right one two yeah that's
five and I think I think it the the
positioning is obviously you need that
head-on view because that's probably the
most important view um and then having
the second headon view on the track was
just kind of a fun sort of production
value thing and this was all Jason's
doing not mine and then the room we were
in The Logical other places is just to
have a shot from each side
so I think partly it depends on where
you're you know where you're taping like
I think you know um I'm sure if you're
know people that are taping these big
specials in these huge theaters I'm sure
the the the the where you put the
cameras is probably a very different
thought process than in a sort of
typical rectangular Club yeah the how
many people were in your audience or how
did y'all feel the audience versus F the
crew like the room seats yeah the room
seats about 100 people but we probably
lost 15ish seats because of the
cameras so I had to fill whatever that
is 85 and um you know you promote the
family and friends
and um the club's going to sell T the
club's going to put it on their website
and email it to their list so they got
some there's some interest there there's
people that had watched the first
one um that that are in the area that
was that came
out you know you know a bunch of people
came from my gym to be supportive uh
nice nice yeah you know if you go like
every 18 months people will come out
they won't come again until I'm taping
something but they come for the you know
for that one is that to the gym or to
the to your special the gym the gym
folks in the gym like this guy's been
talking a big game for years we probably
should
go see what's actually going on so
that's no but that was nice they they
had like a whole big table it was great
um awesome but it's it's nice like you
know if you're not I'm not a draw right
so it's nice you know you or you
strategically want to pick a location if
you're not a draw that that has their
own draw for that night that you're
shooting and like Westside comedy club
in New York is going to get a certain
number of people for Thursday night
shows and my hope is like they get what
they usually get plus I get more because
it's a special event and people that
want to come see me and then I can you
know a good
crowd but like if I tried you know if I
tried to do it in some random place like
I couldn't have done this outside of New
York I just don't know enough people in
another market and I'm not a draw
yet so Zeb
asked does your host prep the audience
and let them know a special is being
recorded if so what are some things you
instruct them to do and
say oh that's a great question um and
and just before I answer it I'll say
that in the first one I had like several
openers um and that's another thing on
my list is like I didn't want to do that
I just had a host and she did you know
20 minutes and then brought me right up
I didn't need a I I don't think I was on
stage the first time until about 45
minutes into the show and I that's not I
didn't want to do that again um my
thought was like well I feel from from
having gone to a bunch of tapings in New
York I feel like everyone is so hyped
that it's a taping you don't need that
extra time to get the audience prepared
and um I want to have as much time like
I wanted to be able to do an hour and a
be on stage for an hour and a half if I
had to and there's a second show so you
had to you know you're gonna get the
better crowd at the first show or at
least I knew I would and I need to have
the time to be able to get every get all
the pickups if I need them I don't want
to be sitting there waiting I just like
I'm amped I'm ready to go um but she did
so um you know she did point out to the
crowd hey this is this is a this is a
you know to amp them up as well hey
you're at a special event this is a
special recording um Adam's going to
come out and do his set and then when he
finishes just stay in your seats because
we're going to do some we might do some
pickups we might do some fun things at
the end um you'll get to see how all
this all gets put together you know she
was very you know she get there was
there was a sort of list of instructions
so the audience understood what was um
how they we hoped they'd behave given
that it was a taping and everyone
everyone was
great very
cool was very cool that is good to know
because I think yeah I had I just had a
friend host mine and he did a setup
front and then basically like built up
this big announcement of like here we go
type deal so it keeps it moving yeah
they're there they're there for you
they're there for the taping don't need
to see three openers you know like yeah
at this for something like for a taping
like this they they just you
know and I also don't want them to get I
don't want them tired at the end of the
set like you might be worried oh what if
they're not like ready for the beginning
well first of all I think they will be
after 20 minutes and yeah um and you're
going to open with with like great jokes
and you're going to close with great
jokes the whole thing's going to be
great of course but like the last thing
you want is them tired when you're
getting into those last few jokes where
you really want your your special to end
strong you don't want a tired crowd for
that because I think Yoshi's playing on
having several openers so I a 15 I was
just gonna make an open mic right before
the special show doing bucket
spots bucket spots you gotta pay you
gotta pay me to go up and then bring her
show and to be clear I look I I had did
have I had think I had three people and
a host the first time and uh yeah you
know you can do it it like it worked I'm
not I don't I'm not I'm just this was
something that I had observed and I
thought that's the way I wanted to do it
for sure by no means I'm wrong about
most things so I could be wrong about
that no no it's just a good I I just
like that you shared your thought
process on well and also to be honest
like it's it's also tricky you know
being a New York Comic in the New York
scene like picking openers I also don't
want to upset anyone by not asking them
to do it so it's a lot easier if I'm
like there's just going to be a
host ah then I'm not you know I don't
have to like explain why I picked one
person versus another or something for
sure speaking of New York Comics oh did
you have a question
Yoshi uh no go ahead you sure yeah yeah
yeah oh okay okay are you sure you
sure so Drew beer
a fellow New York comedian hey yeah hey
Drew he asked did you work with the
director beforehand on the material
order structure or was the director just
there to direct the camera
people I think it's it's more the ladder
like he didn't know the material before
the filming or anything like that um we
did talk once about he was like if you
have any if there's any big Movement
Like physical movements in a joke like
let we can sit down and talk about where
those are in the set because because if
we want one of the cameras to like push
in or pull out or move somewhere or do
something based on a specific bit or a
specific act that we do that um the way
that he had the room set up I didn't
really need any any of that type of
thing um you can also fil like we he
also all the cameras he was using were
also 6K not to get technical but that
means you can punch in and still be 4K
so that's a that's a nice benefit where
you you effectively have mult more
camera angles than you think just being
able to punch in if you film it such
high resolution um so mostly he was just
he was directing kind of the camera
angles following the set noticing if I
screwed something up or if something
like wouldn't like was you know like
when I started a joke while I was
drinking water it's like let's redo the
beginning of that joke so that um so
that I'm not you know holding the water
stuff like that
yeah very nice Jerry croll ad came up
with the set design he was we talked a
little bit about that so like if you see
it with the there's some cool lighting
and and curtains and stuff and that was
that was all him gotcha yeah that is
interesting yeah and looking for a
director or someone to help out like
yeah who what would you recommend like
you mentioned makeup and all that which
is optional like what would you
recommend bringing people in to help
like what would you want the most help
with
when producing your own
special I think it's the C I think it's
the cameras and the audio like the tech
and audio we should this is helpful to
point out because you don't just have
your videographer crew you also have a
separate audio
engineer so because you got to have
someone sitting in the sound booth you
know that's that's put you you know
obviously has the um like the mic feed
but also multiple audience mics who's
watching the levels and making sure all
that gets taped properly because without
good audio it doesn't matter what the
the video looks
like yeah I think that's the most
important thing like if you know good
audio engineer good videographers you
know every and that's those are the most
important things for sure yeah don't put
it all on one person to do everything
like you you definitely want separate
people for the audio and the video
that's their expertise let them just
focus on those things instead of having
to try to run around and make sure the
sound's going and the videos are all
going yeah you really yeah and your your
video people know sound Engineers that
they've worked with in the past that's
great but like so I knew I knew a sound
engineer that had done he he had
recorded several other specials at that
in that same room and i' I'd met him
before I'd been at a special taping
where he was the sound engineer I'd
heard the output so I was like he knows
how this room works from an audio
perspective so he's the right guy to do
itome the director knew all like all the
other people were through the director
like he took care of the the makeup
person and the camera the the you know
still image camera person and all that
stuff I didn't have to find people
separately yeah that makesense but you
so basically you had a video person and
you hired a separate audio person yeah I
had to kind of I had to I had to make I
had to scheduled two people and then
they scheduled everything else got it
yeah
okay oh and this is on Jerry had a
question but Bob um this one's a little
relevant to what we're talking about he
asked what C what was the type of camera
I think you said you had five cameras
but what was the type of camera model
and make that you used oh that's a good
question um I don't actually know but 6K
so yeah they were fil fil at 6K so they
can punch in It'll like the final
product will be 4K and then when you see
it on YouTube if that's where it ends up
which is most likely often that's down
to like 1080 it'll still look great but
excuse me um I'm not sure what the brand
of camera was was to be honest the first
the first special was a couple black
magic cameras in a Sony if that means
anything yeah and black magic does make
6K cameras as well yeah they have a 4K
and a
6K so Jerry croll asks you mentioned
working on material leading up to the
show and working alone in your apartment
did you run the material with some
trusted Comics or other types of
prep oh I mean like all the jokes I was
doing I've done in in front of crowds
many many times um it's just doing them
together as an hour that flows that I
was that you got to that I was doing by
myself in in my room um so it's sort of
like the standard process of you know
whether going to open mics doing shows
you know five minute spots 10 15 um I
feature a lot which is like 20 to 25
minutes so 20 25 minutes is good because
I would I would sort of I'd probably
open with the same five minutes every
time and maybe close with the same same
thing but I could swap out the middle to
over you know if you're doing four
feature sets in a weekend you can get
through the whole
hour um but then you get back in your
room when you want to just go I need to
I need to say these words in order the
whole thing and that's that's me you
know I had and again I had three or four
headliner sets where I was able to do
that and then I and then I was doing it
almost every day in my apartment by
myself the wall did not laugh
once
so um you you mentioned I was hoping for
some Chuckles from a neighbor through an
air vent or something but nothing oh oh
Adam's doing that one again he's like
nice tag
Adam yeah don't forget the airport bit
Yeah Yeah you forgot the skydiving one
last time yeah yeah yeah
yeah and how I think this is something
Pro Comics are may be thinking as they
heard you say at the beginning but how
did you get your stuff on
serious oh so
um so the thing about sir I think I
think Sirius has changed over the last I
don't know three to five years because
it feels like it used to be that anyone
if you had the uh sort of album quality
audio could just kind of submit
something to them um now you do need to
go through a label is my understanding
um so what I did was and this was a
while after the you it had been out on
YouTube um the world series of Comedy
which is a festival where I probably
that's I don't know if it's where I met
you Yoshi if it was through there or
through hot breath it's probably both
but uh they have yeah yeah we saw each
other at the World Series yeah and they
have a um they have a record label now
and they've done a few compilation
albums from their Festival um which is
actually a really cool thing if you do
the festival and the set goes well you
might end up being asked if you want to
be on one of their compilation albums
but I said hey would you guys would you
guys want to produce the audio of my
special and they said absolutely and uh
and did did the sort of back um backend
work to get that all prepped and sent to
serus nice and then you guys will you
have like a split agreement on like the
the spins yeah yeah it's just's pretty
standard Revenue splits and it's all
very easy to do once once it's um done
and you know I you split it into tracks
you name the
tracks it's there and there's a lot of
like metadata that they need like
keywords and stuff and and that's you
know the the label takes care of a lot
of that and uh and then you you know you
wait and hope they accept it and they
did yeah it's a great way to make just
that mailbox money just every month you
you get a check from that stuff it's
very
nice yeah I've gotten one email that
said hey I heard you on Sirus um so I'll
probably get about five or 10 cents
coming to me
soon yeah those are good feelings
hopefully that's not the only time
they've played a track but we'll
see and the last thing I wanted to bring
up is the promotion side because you had
mentioned maybe hiring a PR PR firm for
this one I know in the first one you
talked about you DMD all the followers
of the comedy club you filmed at saying
hey basically this here's the special um
basically yeah you had a you had a whole
we talk about all in the first episode
we did together about that special but
basically that was just unique way to
promote it so I'm curious where you're
thinking on how you can uniquely promote
this
one well I have about five or six times
more YouTube subscribers now than I did
when the first one came out so hopefully
that helps a little bit nice and um and
then there's other people that have
commented on the first
one um like I imagine I can go into
those comments and be like hey the
second one's out if you want to [__] on
that one too um feel free and uh and
then probably follow a similar you know
thing to the first one which is so just
start you know
dming uh through in in some sort of
logical way and sequence people that
might be interested and try to drum up
some interest that
way um I mean if it goes if it just goes
straight to Youtube like the other one
did which is is a there's a good chance
there's there's a there's a chance it
won't um that it'll go through some
other distributor but I think that's
what I that would be the way I would do
the I'd probably replicate the same
thing and hope that it works better
because just simply because there's more
you know a bigger subscriber
base and honestly and I think I also
know I think one of the things that
really helps is
knowing uh knowing Comics that have a
much bigger following than you that
would be willing to repost that you just
did something and so as you advance in
your career and you meet more people and
they like you and want to be helpful and
and um and think you're funny enough
that they could Pro help you promote it
it's pretty easy for them to just
forward you know add to their stories on
Instagram or something
so I think that's just a Natural
Evolution as you meet more people and
network a bit is hopefully you get a
little more help on that end as
well lovely well we're of course happy
to help things like this
like as many of as many as much as you
can
do you have a date that you're it's
going to be released do you have like a
release date for it um I know you were
talking about seeing sort of like the
first cut so do you have like a release
date that you want to get it out to the
world or that's still like a work in
progress still work in progress like my
hope is it's going to be done sometime
in February um given where we are in the
editing like in the editing in the note
process um of going through it like it's
you know my notes have gone to a point
where I'm accidentally undoing my
previous note you know that stage you're
like I think I just said the opposite
thing as I did on the last draft so
we're getting close you know
um and that's so my guess is it
certainly will be done I would think
sometime in in February because what
Happ what has to happen is you you lock
the P you get to picture lock where all
the Angles and it's all you know all the
edits are done then they then they do
all the
colorizing and then they got to send
then they do then they mix the sound so
which could take that could take a
couple weeks if the sound editors are
busy you know um it's not going to be
you know so but it could it could be
ready sometime towards the end of
February and then it's just a question
of what's the is there any is there a
specific date in March that like helps I
don't know yeah yeah so but hope
hopefully if it's just GNA go on YouTube
which is the most likely you know
distribution Channel I would think
sometime in the first half of
March nice are you thinking I think for
comedians are default is self-produce
YouTube what are you what other options
are you exploring or what are you
thinking
there well there's someone that wants to
pitch it to um a distributor and it what
and the difference is it still it just
ends up they end up it would it would
end up getting on all the platforms
faster but um but it might be behind a
pay wall and that's the question right
is you know I think less people are
going to watch something if it's behind
a pay wall you might make more money
but um or you might not it's hard to
know yeah I I sold mine on my website
and yeah just kept it behind there and
it's something people just buy it every
now and then and it's just kind of
income that just comes in like that you
know but the whole goal was selling and
that's smart because you have no
distributor right like it's just you
yeah yeah it's just on my there's no no
one's taking a cut of that which is
fantastic
right if I sold it to someone there's a
question of like and this is this is a
theoretical question but if someone came
in and said we'll give we'll we'll pay
the production costs right and then
there's some sort of Revenue split on
everything that's made after
that um so day one I'm now
even that's an interesting that's an
interesting uh proposition that I would
have to think
about and then I then I have to decide
do I want to keep complete control over
it and get paid way less or do I want to
take all the risk off the table
yeah what was your thought process with
your first one with your first one no
effort was made to sell that first one
to anyone because I just didn't think
anyone would want
it I mean to be honest like I I if you
if you had if I had to guess when that
first one came out like if go back in
time I would have think I would have
been like if a few thousand people watch
this thing that'll be amazing and you
know it's at 140,000 so yep you know you
never know um yeah and it was and I
think it was it was
um better than I it came out better than
I thought it
could it I mean it was it was a huge
step function in me as a comedian just
in terms of confidence because like oh
man I did that and it's not bad that's
you know now let's move forward from
here that creates a new like
Baseline and it and um and I think that
really yeah that really propelled my you
know that's very
motivating
you start want to start writing like and
I felt the same way after this second
one I taped on December 7th and December
8th I was like when can I tape again
that was so much
fun yeah that's legit
dude and um you
know and then I wrote a bunch of new
jokes and they all bombed and I was like
it's gonna be a
while well do you have any uh closing
advice or takeaways about producing her
own special for fellow comedians out
there yeah see look I think I think
there's a there's an element of stress
to it but it's also like really it's a
really fun process to go through um and
I kind of like the whole creative
process from beginning to end so for me
it's very fun to see even like the
postproduction and the editing and
giving the notes it's all um for me it's
all part of that creative process and I
I enjoy it um and there's also nothing
better than
a special recording event and that the
the hype of the audience it's very very
fun um so I would say to anyone like you
know if you're if you're ready and you
have the material by all means do it and
the other thing is and I think this is
actually probably the most important
thing I can say is uh you don't have to
do an hour like if you have a killer 20
minutes and you want to create something
find two other Comics that have killer
20s as well get book a club do two
shows hire the hire the cameraman and do
do it professionally but now you got
three people promoting and bringing in
an audience you know flip the order the
first Show versus The Late Show because
there's nothing a 20 minute special that
kicks ass is great and and that's
fantastic there's no reason you gotta be
like I have 20 great minutes that I want
to put on tape but I need to wait until
I have another 40 no you
don't you could do you know I think no
one's watching my an hour special very
few people are watching from beginning
to end unless the unless it's like Dave
Chappelle or something or you know Bill
Burr like even even when I watch stuff
it's 15 20 minute increments then I go
back to it later and I go you know maybe
it's two or and same thing on YouTube
people are bouncing around um there's
nothing wrong with a good 20 30 minute
special and you could you can team up
with people and split the
costs that's a really good idea I don't
think I yeah that's a really good idea
and if you don't care about that's D
does yeah if you don't care about the
video as much if you just like I got I
got a great 20 minutes I'd love to have
on SiriusXM then you just need an audio
engineer and it's not even that
expensive especially if you split it
with a few other
people
so very very doable look at Adam
dropping Jims Jims Jims Jims J J thank
you so much did uh did we not cover
thank you for having me of course man of
course we yeah you know we've been fans
and love Comics out there Tak action and
taking their career into their own hands
that's the whole it's the whole name of
the game here yeah yeah and uh Adam is
going to be in Atlanta for this weekend
for the West End Comedy Festival I will
also be there so if anybody's in Atlanta
come check us out uh yeah it's G to be
good man it's good to like see you just
rocking I mean you know I think we saw
each other I think the last plot might
have been Florida at the at uh wa wait
what Vegas last year was Vegas yeah yeah
yeah I think I was thinking of um
Sarasota we've we've bumped into each
other across the old world series
circuit a few times absolutely yeah yeah
yeah yeah but that Sarasota remember we
had that killer show we're like we got
to do this club more often that's a
great that is a great spot must been MCC
great yeah crowds are
amazing crowd was incredible we were
like yeah yeah let's run this one back
let's send the email it's too it's too
bad they weren't taping the compilation
albums that year that would have been
fire yeah that was a fire set yeah yeah
good stuff man yeah man congrats on the
new special man that's I'm I'm I'm
excited for you just don't release it
excited for you man I can't don't
release it on February 22nd how about
that just I need I'm just kidding you
can release is that you're taping taping
yeah that's just what I'm taping yeah
yeah I'm not really it's I don't know
when I'm going to release but I'll be
I'll be busy because my dry bar is the
February 23rd so I'll just be I'll just
be trying to remember not to swear on
the
22nd you're doing that with uh who else
are you doing Wellington and June
Coulson yeah nice so yeah Wellington's
OG Atlanta fam and then June's OG hot
brether yeah yeah I got my fingers
crossed I get to go before
Wellington a hilarious well hopefully
you get the spot the the person that
goes up third they they do two comics
and then a candy break so then people
get up and go get candy and popcorn and
then come back so I got to tape the
third spot which meant two Comics then a
fun sugar break and then the third so
make sure that momentum you know ceases
for a minut did you feel the sugar crash
like 15 minutes in
your fortunately more candy more candy
yeah right we've been in fam but I seen
the of the football joke by the way and
I loved it so I can't I seen the whole
special yet but I saw that on YouTube
and that was fantastic I I I had a blast
man you're going to love it out there
they treat you like royalty it's it's
such a positive and fun experience that
I'm glad you're going to get to get to
have because they're they're they're
great people over there yeah yeah no I'm
I'm very
excited nice well if did we miss any
questions you have Yoshi did you for
your special we got them
I think we got through him I was you
know my thing was mostly just about the
rehearsal process um you talked about
the lighting I mean you talked about
sort of just the day of I guess maybe
like one more one last question day of
the special that you taped sort of walk
me through sort of what your day was
like and kind of like the mindset that
you were in for the day of O I was
pretty chill like I didn't I didn't like
rehearse that morning or anything
I um I went you know I got some exercise
I slept in a little bit I slept in as
much as I could got a little exercise
because that just gets my brain going I
want I didn't want to I wanted to make
sure I did something um may have taken
like a 20 or 30 minute nap at some point
in the early afternoon which um you know
whatever but mostly it was just me it
was more of a meditation than a nap I'm
not even sure if I fell asleep and then
uh you know they they wanted me there at
like five so I just got my stuff
together and went over and um kind of
went over the set list a few times but I
I did less specific jokes and more just
the different
blocks because the way I kind of
organized my thing in my head is like
there's blocks like a block might be
Canada and then within that there's you
know six jokes and the next block might
be MIT and there's seven jokes so I just
went I kind of went through my mind just
block to block and just with the
confidence that I know what the jokes
are in in the blocks now and
then um you know got there and was
overwhelmed by all the activity that was
going on um and and I do wish I had
kicked everyone out of the green room
and taken 20 minutes just to go over the
set list yeah in that sort of half an
hour before the show but I didn't really
have that chance and um and it worked
out fine anyway
so but I just you know normal day yeah I
didn't do
anything just try to be you know be well
rested yeah yeah you didn't sacrifice a
goat or nothing like that just I think
even the night before I think I only did
like a and and this isn't necessarily by
choice right this is also by like who
books me but I think I only did like a
maybe like an8 minute Spot somewhere in
the city but I made sure it was early
because I didn't want to be out late and
um yeah and in eight minutes I wasn't
goingon to run the set it was that was
just about being that's just about you
know being comfortable on stage and
loose and fun I didn't even really care
punch lines yeah I wasn't I wasn't
trying to like I wasn't trying to test a
new tag um yeah yeah yeah I will say I
did write well I did come up with a
couple things the morning of that I did
do so I I I'll I'll slip that in at the
end that that that I'm not sure that's a
smart move
um I Rift a few things that are going to
be in the special that came to me that
morning yeah and uh very cool yeah why
not I mean like you said right you you
taped it twice so if it worked I slipped
them into like I did the first kind of
couple minutes as planned then there was
a little couple riffy things if I me you
know so and it was nothing that was like
if this doesn't work it'll ruin the show
it was it's pretty it's you know it's of
pretty
clean kind of like like I I said
something about the fact that it was my
second
special and turned that into a laugh and
think a few things like that for sure
talked about what day it
was I made a joke about the what day it
was which I'll just you know you you you
have to you'll have to buy it to to hear
that joke o can I have that joke I mean
watch a YouTube ad about uh biotics when
it comes
out congratulations that's probably what
they what the algorithm puts on my stuff
probiotics and probotics
and are you monetized are you monetizing
your YouTube special yeah I got the
first special got like halfway through
it well after the first 60,000 views is
kind of when I hit monetization gotcha
so it got my it got my YouTube monetized
which was another reason to do it
because I felt like this can get me the
the subscribers the views I need to
get so this next one would start already
monetized which is great
awesome boom that's awesome
dude well done my friend pushing
it I know second special that's that's
very exciting man it's exciting just to
see you not getting stuck in the old
school mentality
of like well let me wait till X Y and Z
or maybe someday you're saying no I'm
going to make it the day I'm going to
say when the day is and I'm gonna make
it happen I'm gonna put on the calendar
and I'm gonna make myself uncomfortable
and I have this day to have to figure
out something by then and you did it and
that is very difficult to do and very
scary for people at every level in this
game so I salute you for putting it all
in your hands thing you you don't have
to stop doing the material either you
know like mm not a big enough there are
times where someone will bring me up as
like you may you know you may have seen
him on YouTube his YouTube special and
I'll get on stage and I'll be like Make
Some Noise if you've seen my YouTube
special and it's like dead silence and
like that's about
right and that gets a laugh which is fun
but it's like yeah you guys you know
it's a what's the chance of a random 150
people in a room somewhere in this
country that have seen like my YouTube
special when I'm not the headliner if
I'm featuring for someone they haven't
seen it I can do all that stuff you know
and it's like it's fun fun yeah you know
it's not
burned nice yeah that's a good fun
reminder that I think me and Joel have
talked about this year when I was
thinking about my special I was like at
this point who cares no one knows who I
am like maybe in the city but outside
the city I don't think you can burn
material until you you're selling
tickets I think if if you're if a club
is selling like 50% of the room because
they're your fans
yeah then you have to start assuming
they've seen your stuff but until then
yeah you know and you know that'd be a
great problem to have I look forward to
that day and it's not gonna be anytime
soon we all do y
absolutely well we appreciate your time
Adam and appreciate appreciate you
having
me hijack tues
Q yeah yeah yeah come through uh it's
good to know that you'll be in town
although I did not give you the same
courtesy so my
bad
that one's on me that one's on me but
I'm coming
back that place was magical just the
amount of shows were just like
incredible lots of good stuff and I
think that's the other thing I I like
doing that we did like four days and it
was just good just to run into like so
many Comics but also like but also like
watch that much talent in New York dude
new New York comedy
special yeah you guys got like there's
oh yeah that's mea yeah yeah I mean I
think it was for I was fortunate to be
on showcase shows where a lot of the
people like I'm looking at I'm looking
at every single person everyone I
connected with on the shows and I'm
looking at their Instagram ig's every
single person I don't think I met a
single person that had like less than
20,000 followers like legit oh wow yeah
legit just Heavy Hitters doing something
whether it be Tik Tok or Instagram or
YouTube whatever but they're doing
something so that was kind of fun to
like watch that kind of work in that
four day span yeah well where where can
people follow you or reach out with
questions if they have any
Adam uh adam. Mueller on Instagram is by
the best uh the best and you can
certainly DM me on there and then uh the
Youtube channel is Adam Mueller comedy
so if you're not subscribed Please
Subscribe because that's probably where
the special will turn up please
subscribe and you can always and you
please subscribe pretty please with a
cherry on
top and if you've already watched the
first special you know put it on put it
on mute and just let it run in the
living room it's
[Laughter]
fun what about you Yoshi where people
follow you uh follow me on DJ Yoshi on
Instagram and Yoshi so on Tik Tok I'm
starting to get on Tik Tok I'm not there
like fully there yet but I'm starting
I'm I'm I'm dipping my toe in my kids
have to teach me how to do it so uh I'm
making it work uh and then uh special
dates are all up on yoshi. comom
y.com beautiful and y'all can follow me
at Joel buers comedy and we can also
connect hot breath pod on all social
media go join our Facebook group where
you can connect with all three of us and
write jokes together and join our
patreon if you enjoy all this free
education all of it we'll see y'all next
Tuesday for this live stream Again on
YouTube bye
y'all peace